roland garros excite les françaises mais
les garçons sont bien là 3 on joue
aujourd'hui parmi eux gaël monfils qui
se qualifie pour les huitièmes de finale
et 2,4 d'ores et déjà une performance
pour le camp tricolore serge gyan
l'homme élastique a encore frappé et
pourtant
gaël monfils était bien mal parti dans
son duel contre l'autrichien jurgen
melzer
mené deux sets à un
l'ancien champion du monde junior doit
puiser au fond de ses réserves pour
égaliser avant de finir le match entre
ont transcendé par le soutien du public
gaël monfils s'impose 6 2 au cinquième
set il prolonge ainsi la belle aventure
en trois sets et un merveilleux
ça m'a donné vraiment défaire
que ceux des pubs l'est robby ginepri
porte sur ses épaules
les derniers espoirs américains hommes
et femmes confondus dans ce match de
cogneurs florent serra gagne souvent les
points les plus spectaculaires mais le
bordelais perd le match en trois sets le
puissant mais il m'a poussé à la faute
et puis et mamie m'a fait reculer donc
voilà c'est il a gagné un songe là
j'essaie de varier un petit peu mais ça
n'a pas suffi demain débuteront les
huitièmes de finale avec le retour des
français michaël llodra paul henri
mathieu et jérémy chardy le nouveau
chouchou du public